[Music]
okay so this
is my spoiler review of the newest m
night
shyamalan film old this was written by m
knight
shyamalan and directed by m night
shyamalan and
i was very excited for this film i
thought that
he's had a couple recent good directing
and writing bouts that's particular in
the show servant that i cover so i was
disappointed when he kind of
took away time to serve and to do this
film so i'm like hopefully it's good and
i feel like sometimes these movie
directors don't realize they're doing
something so good on tv
and then they're like oh i want to go
back to movies and make a great movie
and they hype it up and you're like okay
well this is what they decided to work
on now and
i hope it's as good as what they've been
doing on tv aka servant for m night but
man look it was one of those trailers
when it came out i was like this could
either be amazing or awful
and it's gonna go one of those ways just
the way it's presented the idea
of this the concept that they're just
filming on a beach here
and i i started watching this movie and
very quickly you start to realize it is
awful
like really bad and i haven't seen a
movie this bad in a long time which
makes it really disappointing because i
really do like most of m knight's work i
think he's a super talented writer and
director
and it's scary that when he drops
sometimes he goes real low like the
happening for example
and he can be really hit or miss but
mostly he's been consistent of late you
know with m knight it's like he goes
forward one step and then he goes really
far back sometimes and this is another
far back situation
so when i do my reviews especially
spoiler when i try to just take notes on
every scene
try to get the concepts of it but this
is one of those films where i couldn't
even focus i was laughing so hard during
it which is crazy because it's supposed
to be a psychological thriller and i
find myself
feeling like i'm watching a scary movie
parody movie one of the scary movie
films like
i couldn't believe what i was watching
and why it's crazy is because you think
you know how smart m knight is as a
director and a writer
and you're like when he's watching this
he must be feeling what i'm feeling
watching it right like there's no way
there's no
way he doesn't feel that or even people
in this cast when they go to premiere
like
how do you not feel that or even on set
i mean
first off a thing a lot of people are
gonna complain about it's tough to pull
off with this concept of people getting
older which is
on paper this film is a great idea you
know it's based off this graphic novel
sand castles and you would think you
could do some really cool things with
this
because people are getting older and i
do actually like how they reveal a bit
when the kids are getting older
and it comes from someone else's
perspective figuring it out before you
see it i like that
but they don't keep the consistency up
with the ages the way they decide to
have them grow
from like 6 to 16 in a second but then
they kind of stop till the end of the
movie was inconsistent
and then really the older people it made
sense with their cells how they were
growing the pace they're going but then
we only see a couple of them kind of
grow older i think they could have
thought of so many different scenarios
for scenes
when they're getting older and what's
happening to them and they just do some
random stuff like in particular
i felt back because i love eliza scanlon
right there from sharp objects and
she's just completely wasted here her
pregnancy
scene was like what like what was the
point of that there's little lines they
throw in that make you laugh like you
know the boy who's now
growing up that had sex with her is
telling his parents
oh i thought it was you know they don't
get pregnant unless you do it like 10
times not one time
and it's like these lines like that just
make you like roll your eyes and laugh
but the hardest i laughed during this
film and where i was really like okay
this is bad
and lost it was when eliza scanlan's
character is climbing up this
rock and she decides you know what i'm
getting off the silence like no
and they're all screaming for and her
mom's nowhere to be found and then she
just falls i was like
oh my god what is going on and why that
also
just leads to a strange storyline is
with her mom who's played by abby lee
she is from lovecraft country which she
was also great in
she's completely wasted here and then
they have her character do this like
storyline that you see in a lot of like
you know
fables where she's like scared of what
she's becoming it's like the old witch
story line i'm becoming a witch that's
the way she's reacting to her
transformation and it's like
just comes off laughable the way they do
it and her walking around in the cave
one of the few positives of this film
though was i did think it was cool with
the body horror he did with her
character at the end of that one shot
when she kind of you see all her
limbs moving out i thought that actually
was really cool but
that's a very small positive of the
whole film
now a character that was really just
probably the worst character was this
crazy doctor
here who was obsessed with using a knife
to want to just slash people
and he really doesn't get any payoff
none of these characters really get any
payoff but
what was really odd was they had a huge
horror film trope just happened right
away where they killed the black guy
first
which was insane to me and it's it's
filled with tropes
this film like they haven't ever seen a
horror film before and stuff people
laugh at and don't want anymore and they
just do it
and that's why shocking m knight did
this you know but with the guy with the
knife too it's like he was just there to
shake things up and a lot of these
characters there just serve those kind
of like plot purposes but
there's not really anyone you care about
it's supposed to be
you know vicky creep's character the
main character and
i don't even know what i'm supposed to
care about and
it falls flat in that sense because you
can see that you try to set the cancer
storyline with her
to pay off towards the end but it gets
sloppy it gets lost and they decide to
come back at it here and there
it continues on with these laughable
deaths where they could have made such
cool things with the growing
older concept and you have the character
from lost
it's funny he's on an island again but
he just you know tells his wife i'm
gonna go swim out to uh
the other shore and then we just see him
couple minutes later
just wash up in the waves dead you know
we didn't even get to see how he exactly
died
and then his wife eventually was like oh
i think i have a sit i'm gonna go see my
sister i have these noodles and then she
has
this seizure and dies it's these like
random deaths that don't have any weight
to them
and it's just chopping off people one by
one again another hard trouble which is
going through the list of let's suppose
people on island eventually just kill
them all and leave
our main characters and try to throw in
a quick theme with the parents towards
their kids
which to me did not land it's really
weird because it's like i feel like i'm
not
sent out to make a crazy psychological
thriller and i'm sure on paper this
looked like a great concept i think if i
read
even the script maybe i still think it
was okay but it's just an example of
something where it's like no
it doesn't come out as imagined and it
came out like it's unintentionally made
a rip roaring comedy here
like i haven't laughed that hard in a
long time and
i mean it's that bad that i feel like
you could enjoy this like
it's not at the point where it's like
it's just a boring movie you don't want
to watch it like you can enjoy and just
see like what not to do in a film
and there's just moments you just start
cracking up and
it's sad though because that you wanted
to see an amazing thriller here and
i saw one critic on twitter the night of
just like say like oh it takes a little
while to get off but then it's like gets
amazing and it's moving like a bat out
of hell like who are these people you
know like who
what is he watching you know i it just
blows my mind
but i'm giving this one a 2.9
uh it's the lowest score of giving
anything i think ever
and that's like jordan peele's twilight
zone show where i gave all scores close
to that but still didn't go that level
but this felt like a bad episode of
twilight zone
any error um yeah i mean i don't know
like universal buys this from m night
releases it
i mean i think it's just his name at
this point right because there's no way
they would have bought a movie like this
there's
no way like this is just not good like
this is a favorite for the razzies for
sure
i know i'm renting here but i'm very
passionate about how much this film just
shocked me how bad it was
it's unfortunate because i really still
think i'm not super talented but you
just wonder what was going on here man
what are you doing here are you pulling
money out of our pockets or what like
what is going on so
i don't know i i have nothing else to
say but you know what if you like what i
said here you can subscribe you can
check out
uh you can become a member you can
support that would be amazing you get
exclusive perks and i also do celebrate
interviews as well and please follow me
at steve varley show on twitter
instagram and tick tock where you can
see short versions of my reviews
and i'll see you next time